[Music]
yeah hi I for got my skull got a skull
necklace on today I thought I'd be
festive uh I don't know if you know
where I am surprise surprise surprise
surprise at the Apple
Store So I says to the guy I'm at the
Apple Store and I'm going to get myself
an iPhone going to get myself an iPhone
there's a line
line for an iPhone there's a guy over
there you see
him over there
security uh yeah I'm at the Apple Store
again got a Jamba
Juice really good strawberry Sy Rider
what's up uh
yeah we should give out like prizes to
anyone who can guess your location guess
my location this I can actually see
guess my location and I will give you a
t-shirt first person to guess t-shirt
for
you